En lugar de decirme,
Karla, esto debes de hacer,
esto no debes de hacer,
esto está bien o esto está mal,
mi papá prefiere contarme historias.
Sus historias son lo que ha formado
las decisiones que tomo en la vida
mucho más de lo que él se puede imaginar.
Les doy un ejemplo:
cuando tenía 10 años mi papá vivió
una de las situaciones más escalofriantes
que alguien se puede imaginar.
Regresando de una cena familiar
en Cuernavaca se encuentra
con una de las nanas
flotando boca abajo en la alberca.
Mi papá se echa inmediatamente al agua,
saca a la jovencita de la alberca
intenta desesperadamente
todo lo posible por revivirla
sin ningún éxito.
Yo no me enteré hasta años después
de lo que pasó
pero mi papá me cuenta que esa noche
acostado en la cama sin poder dormir
lo único que puede ver es la imagen
de la pobre niña flotando en la alberca.
Así que decide pararse de la cama,
regresar a la alberca
sentarse en una silla
mirando fijamente a la alberca,
viendo el trauma frente a frente.
Incómodo.
Las imágenes resurgiendo,
el cuerpo, su pelo mojado,
su familia, la muerte, la culpa,
los hubieras corriendo por su mente.
¿Por qué nos fuimos a cenar?
¿Por qué se metió a nadar sola
si no sabía nadar?
¿Cómo? ¿Por qué? Hubiera.
Sigue enfrentado, sentado en esa silla,
sin quererse parar hasta poder vencer
esos pensamientos.
Pasan siete horas, apenas
empieza a salir el sol
y mi papá intenta recordar otros momentos
momentos felices que también habíamos
vivido en esa alberca.
Vacaciones, juegos, risas; y poco
a poco, esa imagen o ese trauma
empezaron a perder poder sobre mi papá.
En los momentos donde yo más
quiero salir corriendo,
huir, evadir,
me acuerdo de esta historia.
Sus historias me invitan
a atreverme a lo incómodo.
A lo que más me da miedo.
Y hoy es ese el caso.
Cuando me invitaron a dar
una conferencia TED Talk
mi primera reacción fue "ni de loca".
No, no, invítenme a actuar
cualquier personaje,
a interpretar a una borracha,
a cantarles desentonada
una pedante, una perturbada,
perversa criminal.
A una estudiante de leyes asesina,
lo que quieran y feliz se los hago.
Mismo pídanme
interpretar a la actriz
y posar en frente de
las cámaras en Hollywood
gente de todos, las estrellas
de Hollywood
con tacones incómodos,
demasiado maquillaje, sonreír,
y contestar esas preguntas indiscretas
que les encanta hacer.
Pídanme hacer eso y feliz se los hago
pero pedirme que sea yo misma
quitarme las máscaras
de los personajes con las que me escondo
venir a este escenario
y exponerme honesta
y sinceramente con Uds.
el resultado son retortijones en el
estómago, insomnio y muchas ganas
de decir: "No, perdón, es
que por la agenda no puedo.
Así que espero que mi papá esté
orgulloso de que esté aquí con Uds.
Sus historias son mi herencia.
Y son lo que me mueven
en la dirección menos cómoda.
Vivimos en una sociedad donde tratamos
de evadir esos momentos incómodos.
Esos momentos difíciles a toda costa.
Una sociedad que nos vende ideas.
Ideas que en mi opinión
son mentiras muy bien maquilladas.
Desde las sencillas como:
"Sin ejercicio ni dieta pierde
15 kilos en 2 días".
"Aprende todo un idioma en tan
solo dos semanas".
O los sutiles filtros que
les ponemos a las fotos que
subimos a las redes sociales que
son versiones perfectas e irreales
de quiénes somos y nos ahogan
cuando tratamos de mantener
esa imagen o ese estándar.
O qué me dicen de las vidas
de Rafa Márquez,
Rodolfo Neri, Inárritu
o Frida Kahlo que
los pintan como seres superdotados
que únicamente llegaron al éxito
por su talento
y no por horas y horas de experiencia,
trabajo y fracaso a diario.
Lo peor es que nos creemos esas mentiras.
No saben las veces que
la gente llega a mí y me dice:
"Karla ¿cómo le hago para lograr
mis sueños en la vida?"
Es que quiero ser actriz,
mi mamá y mi tía me dicen
que soy buenísima.
Y cuando les pregunto: ¿Bueno y qué
clases o que cursos estás tomando?
No bueno, pues es que
todavía no pero bueno,
es que mi mamá y mi tía me dice que
ya estoy lista para empezar a actuar.
Mentira.
Tengo un video de cuando tenía 12 años
actuando para un proyecto de la escuela
para que se den cuenta que
mis ganas de ser actriz
no eran suficientes para hacerlo.
¿Ven cómo era importante que
fuera a estudiar horas y horas?
Sigo tomando clases de actuación.
Mi autor, bueno,
uno de mis autores favoritos,
Malcolm Gladwell prueba esta
teoría en su libro "Outliers"
Toma casos de éxitos y genios
que normalmente pensamos que
así nacieron, superdotados
y calcula que en realidad tuvieron
más de 10 000 horas
de experiencia y estudio en su campo
antes de ser titulados genios o expertos.
Yo practiqué gimnasia olímpica
durante 8 años
entrenaba 5 horas diarias
de lunes a sábado,
con llagas en las manos
dejando sangre en las barras
me tenía que seguir esforzando,
sabiendo que lo tenía que hacer
para seguir siendo parte del equipo.
Levantándome a las 5 de la mañana
para ir a entrenar antes de la escuela
sacrificando viajes,
fiestas, noviecitos.
Esos 8 años me enseñaron que la medalla
de oro no se gana accidentalmente
el músculo se tiene que
desgarrar para crecer.
El músculo se tiene que desgarrar
para poder crecer.
Aunque entiendo la ciencia detrás de esto
entonces por qué aun así maldigo
los momentos en los que
la adversidad me toca la puerta.
Imaginen esto, estoy en el primer día
en la escuela de actuación en Londres;
audicionan 5000 chavos
y solo aceptan a 15 mujeres
y a 15 hombres.
así que cómo pueden imaginarse
me siento un poquito demasiado especial.
Y ese primer día llega
uno de los profesores
más respetados y nos dice:
"En 5 años solo 3 de los 30
que están aquí van a tener
trabajo en esta carrera".
Cómo 10 % pero, digo,
si todos somos talentosos,
no creo que sea tan difícil.
Y cómo fueron pasando los meses,
6 se salieron el primer año,
unos cambiaron de profesión,
de carrera,
unos los perdimos por crisis
emocionales y mentales
y mismo un amigo mío: Robin.
Uno de los actores más talentosos
de esa escuela se suicidó.
Es difícil.
Cualquier carrera que Uds. quieran hacer
es y va a ser difícil.
Entonces, ¿cuál es tu gasolina?
¿Qué hará que aguantas vara
en los momentos más oscuros
más difíciles con los que
te vas a encontrar?
¿Qué es, como diría
una abogada en la serie
"How To Get Away With Murder"
tu motivo?
No juzgo, si tu motivo es ser millonario
si tu motivo es ser famoso
lograr que tu ex se arrepienta
de haberte cortado,
está bien.
Lo único que digo es que ese motivo
debe de estar tan arraigado a tu ser,
tan impregnado en tu piel
que no importa la tormenta,
el rechazo,
la crítica que recibas,
ese motivo hará que te levantes
y que le sigas dando.
"Karla, perdón, estamos buscando a
alguien más famoso para este papel".
Levántate Karla, ándale sigue.
"Karla estamos buscando a alguien
menos famoso para este papel".
"Más latina, menos latina,
más flaca, menos flaca".
"Ándale Karla, síguele, síguele".
La cantidad de nos,
rechazo y críticas que recibo
a diario varían de comentarios
de productores como esos
a comentarios en Twitter como:
"No, pues no me gustó tu actuación".
O "estás guapa pero estás bien bizca".
"Patas de pollo".
O comentarios de familiares y amigos
¿Karla por qué te vas a ir a Hollywood?
Estás loca, ubícate.
Nunca la vas a hacer.
Emm, ¿en dónde iba?
Ah, ¡sí!
Un día...
recibo aviso de un casting para
una película llamada "El jesuita"
escrita por el mismo cuate que escribió
"Taxi driver", "Raging bull";
Paul Schrader.
Están buscando a una actriz de mi edad.
Así que le llamó a la señorita del casting
"Karla, perdón,
lo que pasa es que los productores
están buscando a alguien que pueda...
Los productores no creen que puedas
interpretar este papel".
Bueno, conocía a uno de los productores
así que le llamo: "Karla,
mira lo que pasa es que estamos
buscando a alguien que pueda interpretar
a una tejana tosca y racista".
¡Perfecto! Yo, yo puedo darte eso.
"Claro Karlita...
Mira, lo que pasa es que el director
cree que eres muy bonita,
muy delicada...
Estamos buscando a alguien
que parezca una drogadicta".
Me cuelga.
Bueno, estoy enojada y frustrada por qué
solo quería tener la oportunidad de hacer
la audición pero ni siquiera
eso me quieren dar,
así que consigo el guion.
Me aprendo una escena.
Le pido a mis amigos maquillistas
y peinadores que me ayuden
a verme menos "delicada".
Rento una cámara, unas luces
y al día siguiente
le mando esto al productor.
Pasaron dos semanas y no recibí
contestación al email.
De repente recibo una llamada
y es el productor con el director:
"Karla, te ofrecemos el papel".
Entonces filmamos la película,
pero ¿qué creen?
La película no ha salido
y ni siquiera sé si vaya a salir.
Ojalá y sí, pero a veces se siente
que el esfuerzo no valió para nada.
Pero esa experiencia no me la quita nadie
y además le agregué a mis 10 000 horas.
El éxito es la habilidad
de ir de fracaso en fracaso
con entusiasmo, como
bien lo dijo Churchill.
Y yo creo que un buen motivo
te puede ayudar a hacer eso.
Sin embargo, mi motivo no siempre
ha sido el mismo, cambió.
Hace 8 años.
Drásticamente.
Estaba al final de mi primer año
de los 3 años de la carrera
de actuación en Londres
y un día sin razón alguna pierdo el habla
Durante 3 meses.
No puedo hablar, durante
3 meses no puedo decir
ni un miserable enunciado.
Ni los doctores,
ni los electroencefalogramas
han podido explicarme qué fue
lo que realmente pasó.
Lo que si les puedo decir es que
llegó un momento de tanta frustración
y tanta desesperación que llegué
a quererme quitar la vida.
En ese momento busco dentro de mí
la fuerza que yo creía tener
busco la ayuda de mi familia,
de mis amigos,
mi fe en Dios y no encuentro nada.
No hay cura, no hay salida.
Mi motivo, mi gasolina rápido
se empieza a desvanecer y se acaba.
El infierno en el que
me encuentro, sin embargo,
se vuelve un poquito menos pesado
cuando empiezo a ver mi dolor.
El mismo tipo de dolor reflejado
en las obras de arte de otras personas.
Las obras de teatro en las películas,
en las pinturas.
Poco a poco, empiezo a ver mi dolor
y lo empiezo a leer en los poemas
las palabras de los poetas
y de los personajes empiezan
a llenar mis silencios.
Empiezan a ser la única forma en que
la que yo sentía que mis emociones
empiezan a ser expresadas.
Leo mi dolor en los poemas
de Sylvia Plath:
"Me inclino a ti entumecida como
un fósil, dime que estoy aquí".
Me conecto con
el cuestionamiento constante
de la vida en los libros de Jack Kerouac;
veo las pinturas de Frida Kahlo
y por primera vez
puedo palpar ese sufrimiento
y esa soledad de sus autorretratos.
El arte de convierte en algo vivo.
Durante esos 3 meses de silencio,
de presión y angustia
me enamoré inexplicable, completa
y totalmente del arte.
El sufrimiento me llegó como
un clavo al corazón de Dios.
Y me entristece saber que
hay gente que no cree
que el arte es digno de nuestra atención
y de nuestro financiamiento.
Por qué para mí no es solo una pasión,
es lo que me salvó la vida,
lo que me mantuvo viva.
Otra prueba llegó hace 3 años
cuando me gané la lotería;
me enamoré de un hombre.
Llamémosle Pedro por
conservar su anonimato.
Me quería casar con Pedro.
O sea, que estaba muy enamorada.
Fui descubriendo que la familia de Pedro
aquí en México es muy poderosa,
tenían muchísimo dinero,
mucho más de lo que
yo imaginaba que existía
mucho más de lo que podría
gastarme en toda una vida.
Un día me sientan, me dicen:
"Karla te adoramos,
queremos que seas parte
de nuestra familia
solo tenemos una condición:
deja la actuación.
Te apoyamos en lo que quieras
en cualquier otra profesión que elijas
pero deja la actuación,
porque si sigues actuando
no vas a poder ser una esposa fiel,
no vas a poder ser una buena madre
y queremos lo mejor para ti.
Me ardían los ojos.
Me levanto
y le digo adiós a Pedro y a su familia.
Me doy la media vuelta y salgo
sin saber qué iba a hacer de mi vida
pero sabiendo eso sí que el llamado
que Dios tiene en mi vida
mis sueños y mi pasión no tienen precio.
Y esa historia le encanta a mi marido,
que está aquí.
¿Por qué les cuento estas historias?
Por qué la gente normalmente cree
que el éxito y la fama son algo
maravilloso y fácil de navegar.
Estas pruebas para mí
generan frutos como el perdón,
la perseverancia, la disciplina,
el carácter y la esperanza.
Son lo que afilan mi oficio
y lo que con mucha, mucha paciencia
van afinando mi ser
y me liberan de mi orgullo.
He aprendido que el aplauso
dura solo un momento
y esa fama que buscamos tan obsesivamente
es una mera burbuja que tan
fácilmente se poncha.
No tengo la fórmula secreta de cómo
lograr tus sueños y metas en la vida.
Yo sigo aprendiendo conforme avanzo
con la ayuda de las historias de mi papá
me sigo atreviendo a enfrentar mis miedos
le sigo agregando a mis 10 000 horas
para lograr excelencia en mi oficio
y me sigo atreviendo a usar
los sufrimientos
para que me continúen llegando
como un clavo al corazón de Dios.
Algunas ideas y descubrimientos
personales que tenemos en la vida
de alguna forma no pueden ser compartidas
no pueden ser explicadas.
Solo pueden ser reveladas,
solo pueden ser vividas.
Sin embargo espero que las
palabras de mi compadre
William Shakespeare puedan resonar
con Uds. a lo largo de su camino:
"Dulces son los frutos de la adversidad,
que como un sapo feo y venenoso
lleva en la cabeza una preciosa joya".
La adversidad
muchas veces
se ve como ese sapo,
feo y venenoso
pero cada que llega,
cada que surge el desafío
ahora que lo pienso
en el camino si le escarbo,
me encuentro con una preciosa joya
Gracias.
(Aplausos)